do you know who mr wonderful is mr
wonderful shark tank kevin o'leary oh
kevin earlier pull this guy up real
quick let me pull this guy up i told you
there it is so
and he's somebody that hated on crypto
for a while yeah old man i don't like
this new stuff don't like all this
crypto [ __ ]
currency
so the shark tank investor aka mr
wonderful kevin o'leary he says he wants
to double his crypto holdings right
so double let's put that in perspective
i got a better analogy for this you know
what this is yeah bitcoin is that new
new kid in school who had this big party
and like everyone's going and you're at
the party and then you see like the
coolest kids there kevin o'leary and
bank of america oh this kid's legit
these are the coolest kids in school and
they're at his party yeah he's legit
yeah he's in okay that's what exactly
what it is
they're not the parents anymore what was
it a few years ago
before it was like
it was like oh he's he's kind of weird
he's kind of weird kind of weird he's
talking about taking over the world and
how he's going to change things super
weird he's got a little weird music he
dresses but now it's like oh no you're
oh he's kind of cool oh he's having this
party oh let's go oh it's sick oh kevin
o'leary's here oh this kiss
oh oh kevin o'leary's at the party
hold my beer wow
not to freak you out but kevin o'leary
just walked in
this party's sick
[Laughter]
he says he wants to at least double his
cryptocurrency holdings by the end of
the year okay he predicts that trillions
of more dollars could pour into the
market now keep in mind when he says he
wants to raise his exposure i'm gonna
raise my exposure i'm gonna double up he
only has three percent of his uh
investment portfolio into crypto he
wants to go to seven
i say this all the time i've said these
exact numbers all the time
look i'm not saying you need to be 100
crypto i'm not saying you need to be 100
bitcoin i know people like that they're
like yeah all my money's in bitcoin i've
got like
three months of savings six months of
savings the rest is in crypto yeah it's
a little aggressive
but i also don't think you should have
zero i said follow the big boys what are
the big boys doing somewhere between
three and eight percent look at mr
wonderful look how wonderful he is he
just went from three to seven percent so
that's something you should consider um
again he's not going all in he's pretty
savvy but he understands that the money
might be flowing this way
um
you know anyone saying going all in
not the right advice yeah okay never go
on um
so he
just to keep in mind not everyone is
always right he predicted that bitcoin
would was garbage and that it was going
to zero and now he says this is not
going away and it's a new asset class so
which one is it kevin pick one bro pick
one bro pick a path mr wonderful well
look mr indecisive
yeah
mr flip-flop
mr flip-flop
um
well the the important lesson here for
most people is that it's okay to change
your mind from time to time it's okay to
say i was wrong about this yeah and
correct it the worst thing to say is no
no i'm doubling down on being wrong and
nobody can change my mind that's true i
am digging in i am i am i am locking in
and you cannot tell me anything else i'm
doubling down a hundred
what if he goes back what if he's like
never mind no i was wrong
i thought i was wrong before but now i'm
definitely wrong you know what so it's
like all right let's remember this
conversation
kevin o'leary thought that crypto was
quote unquote garbage
realized it wasn't went to three percent
now he's doubling down going to seven
percent let's follow the money buddy
let's see ftm
ftm follow the money
um say kevin but he says that his
there's a major concern of his by the
way keep changing he says the one thing
that there's a one thing i don't know
about this there's one thing in mind
regulation
okay it says regulation yeah he says i
don't want to get involved in crypto if
the regulator says it's not okay oh the
regulations oh my god okay i can't he
says i can't afford to be offside and i
can't afford to be non-compliant
nerd alert oh my god this geek he's he
he's the one that's like oh my god are
you guys drinking no i'm calling the
parents
you're so funny no i'm calling the cops
so that seems to be the the big question
in crypto in all seriousness so the
government regulators coming in like
they're freaking warren g over here and
be like time to regulate yeah
yeah he's like exactly if the parents
are coming i don't want to go exactly
look regulation taxes red tape you know
putting uh impediments to everything
that's happening in the marketplace so
the point is this if you're going to
take anything from the segment bitcoin
has boomed since um bank of america
joined the equation it was under 50. now
it's approaching 60. kevin o'leary shark
tank mr wonderful he thought it was
trash zero went to three now he's
talking about going to seven what are
you gonna do with your portfolio now's
the time if you're at zero to say look
all right yeah maybe i'm putting a grand
in the bitcoin go sit at the cool kids
table go sit at the cool concert okay
walk around walk by it'd be like hey can
i sit here yeah it's 57k to sit here
you can buy a fractionalized shirt you
can buy a fractionalized you can sit at
the corner so um that's what's going on
in the crypto world
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
size cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken